[Music]
in tonight's whatever happened to
segment those massive sinkholes and the
families whose homes were swallowed up
Adrian Collins asked on Facebook what is
the update of the massive sinkholes in
America are they being filled in or what
correspondent Phil Keating looks at the
spectacle and the science behind the
sinkholes just minutes later the first
house dropped into the still growing
sinkhole
it took the sides of the of the ground
away it was alive Jerry doin ran
door-to-door alerting his Land O Lakes
Florida neighbors that their lives as
they knew them were disappearing
dangerously fast it's like quicksand you
could see the water was swirling within
two hours two homes were gone eight
others were condemned including his
leaving the lakefront neighborhood stuck
with this sinkhole smack in the middle
of the road we didn't lose the house but
we lost the house because we can't live
here and you know we probably won't be
able to live here again you're grabbing
your pets and your kids and and just
running you don't have time to really
get anything the University of South
Florida in Tampa uses virtual reality
mapping to study sinkholes right in the
heart of what's known as sinkhole alley
every state has its risks right so it
could be wildfires if you're somewhere
it could be tornadoes if you're
somewhere in Florida we have hurricanes
and we have sinkholes we live on
swiss-cheese essentially Florida leads
the nation in sinkholes where insurers
pay out about a quarter billion dollars
a year for sinkhole calamities but much
of the country is also at risk sinkholes
happen when the ground upon which we
live sits atop porous rock like
limestone which slowly gets eaten away
by the underground aquifer when the rock
gets too weak it crumbles into the water
with everything above it sinking down
with it how do we prevent this from
happening we're a long ways away from
that answer Pasco County safety
administrator Kevin Guthrie says
homeowners on suspect land can fortify
their houses by pinning them onto
limestone but even with driving pipes
deep into the earth to secure their
homes foundations homeowners are not
guaranteed their homes won't collapse
into a sinkhole
if the sections of the bedrock erode
that's the part none of which really
matters anymore for doing there's no
value on this you know at all really
except for it's a parcel that's on the
lake with a big hole out in front and
clearly very costly Pasco County
estimates it would cost 12 million
dollars to patch this sinkhole alone and
make it pristine and no one can
absolutely say whether another
cold will happen to just drop right here
below my feet and for homebuyers well
there's expensive sinkhole insurance as
well as extensive research before you
buy Chris very cool thank you fell